by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and boy oh boy do we
have a special episode for you i
probably say that every week but this
week i truly mean it and we're gonna
come in hot and i'm gonna tell you a
little quote that i read that i thought
was highly relevant i thought it was
highly accurate and i think i'm to keep
it at the top of my notes for every
single episode to remind myself and
maybe read it out to you
to explain the origin of why people hate
someone who hates you normally hates you
for one of three reasons they see you as
a threat they hate themselves
or they want to be you
and that's a quote by
unknown
now i bring that up because again the
theme of this show we do hater of the
week i write jokes for myself and make
fun of myself and yada yada but
i do honestly think it's important for
everybody to compartmentalize
if you are receiving any sort of
harassment online
uh or in your real life
it really does boil down to these three
things i'm not saying everybody who
hates me is jealous of me or has this
excessive antagonism if you don't want
to use the word hate
but
they either then hate themselves or
see me as a threat
right or want to be me you know so
these options to me pretty much sum up
the only possibilities because if if it
wasn't one of those possibilities
what could it be
if you look don't like somebody's
podcast for example you wouldn't watch
it
but hatred goes to something else that
animates you to be proactive and feel
like you're responding something to
something that was done to you
so i want to get right into it before we
even go to what's up fool with a section
i like to call heller rhetorical is that
what we called it before i don't know
but i'm going to give you a definition
of a word that i have been seeing a lot
lately specifically coming from people
who are fans of the h3 podcast and the
[ __ ] who hosts that
so
uh the word bully has been banted around
um
people who are good friends of mine
have been called bully bully bully bully
bully
bully behavior
you're a bully you bullied me
and
when it comes to rhetoric and breaking
down arguments the foundation of the
language that we use to have these
arguments and debates and come at the
truth is the definitions of words you
might talk to a libertarian who will
tell you taxation is slavery but he has
to
manipulate the word
slavery
so much that it loses its real
definition becomes so broad that
anything you're doing that you don't
want to do you know your mom makes you
wash the dishes and that's slavery right
um so
you have to first agree to a standard
definition of a word before you can move
forward otherwise the entire
conversation gets muddled and it's
pointless and you're talking past each
other but one person is going to be
wrong because they're using a word
in an inappropriate way bullying is an
ongoing
key word there ongoing and deliberate
misuse of power
if you don't have any power you can't
bully anyone in relationships through
repeated verbal physical and or social
behavior that intends to cause physical
social and or psychological harm it can
involve an individual or group misusing
their power or perceived power over one
or more persons who feel unable to stop
it from happening the american
psychological association defines
bullying is a form of aggressive
behavior in which someone intentionally
and
repeatedly
causes another person injury or
discomfort bullying can take the form of
physical contact words or more subtle
actions
a bully can be an aggressive juvenile an
intimidating boss or colleague a
controlling romantic partner an unruly
neighbor a high pressure sales business
representative a condescending family
member a shaming social acquaintance or
there was a variety of other types of
abusive relationships but the key word
there and the key theme there
is ongoing
with intention to cause
injury or discomfort
for the sake of such so
if for example
you get an argument with a friend over a
misunderstanding
and you were really pissed at that
person because they thought you did
something like
steal your car and then it turns out
oh i just parked it in the wrong place
my bad and you apologize is that a form
of bullying i would say that's a
misunderstanding that led to some
unfortunate anger and if the person
apologizes afterwards well
it proves my point that it can't be
ongoing and it can't be something that
you know bullies tend to not apologize
on their own accord right
so
i've gotten a lot of
accusations that you know for example
brendan's a bully
in my dms people write to me and i go
talk to this one guy go give me one
example of that
gives me a story from uh a video
that brendan told five years ago about
playing college football and getting
into a
conflict with his roommate
that ultimately ended in him pushing him
through a glass door
but during a fight
and
again that's one of these things where
their peers it's not ongoing
they're going back and forth to each
other escalating the situation and i
played college football too
at the d3 level we had fist fights every
day
people we would [ __ ] in each other's
helmets
um you know we would poke fun at each
other's bodies is that bullying i don't
think so because we all participated it
back and forth and if you're free to
retaliate against it
well
then you're sort of in a
an equal more egalitarian dynamic that
really cancels out any notion of
bullying if you're on the same plane as
an acquaintance or you have a bigger
platform
or you're more successful
or you have these same social
connections and influence
then
it makes a claim of bullying
a little bit hard to make
you can't have isolated incidents of
emotion based on misunderstandings
qualifies that so it's just something in
general i'd like to
clear that up and we will do more of
this as we need to define words in order
to make a case that some people are
telling the truth and some people are
misusing
the most basic elements of language to
paint false narratives
that serve to portray themselves as
victims and disqualify others for being
victims because you know what bullying
also is
years of online harassment deliberately
intended to ruin someone's self-esteem
attacking their physical appearance
attempting to contact sponsors
attempting to
um
you know artificially lower somebody's
rating which has been done to me right
on spotify
coordinated uh campaigns and that's fine
and i don't like
i don't consider myself a victim of
bullying or put thought into that but
the fact is i am and just because i'm
larger or i'm a guy or whatever you have
to apply these terms equally right you
can't just say well one gender one kind
of person can be a bully and
or back can be the victim of bullying
the other can't based on
you know
any other factors but
whether or not they've been
the victim of bullying so
i also you know what i want to say
the way that we deal with bullying in
america too
in case you can probably confirm this
right like
when you were a kid they'd be like just
walk away or you know they sort of like
the campaign to stop bullying is like
like let's let's
let's talk to the bullies and get them
to stop and it's like
you might want to empower the kids to
fight back because there's no reason for
you to be bullied if you can defend
yourself right you know and of course
some situations aren't
always like that where there are really
disparate social dynamics but on the
school yard you know
teach a kid to box teach a kid it's okay
to fight back and so this whole like
zero tolerance policy for fighting or
whatever i used to hate that in school
it's like some kid punches you in the
face and you punch your back and you're
both suspended right that kind of
teaches you like violence is never okay
it's never okay to defend yourself and
you can't defend yourself and that's not
a legitimate strategy to deal with
somebody who's harassing you because if
you do punch a bullet in the face then
he's going to stop right
uh because they're not counting on that
but
again
growing up you know
i was never a bully and i got picked on
i remember some would like this
girl knew me in middle school
and like i was dating somebody who like
later on where she's like oh i knew mark
in middle school like he used to pick
kids up and throw him in the trash cans
and i was so like
taken aback like i eat because that's
not true but like i was bigger you know
i was like six feet tall in eighth grade
and so it's like oh like
you're doing this thing where it's like
mark was big he bullied people no i
didn't never did that
and so to just cavalierly say that and
that's you know
that's a form of bullying lying about me
behind my back but it is like you know
that's
i hate when people do that they put you
know
force you to defend yourself
from afar in the future
not cool
mara
all right moving on
well folks if it's a tuesday morning you
know i got my kratom in my system happy
hippo herbals.com is the place that i
get my kratom why because it's the
highest quality ingredients and you know
what you're getting and it comes in a
variety of
delivery methods you got the pills you
got the powder you got the liquid
however you wanted i've been dry school
muted lately actually like i tried
mixing it up and i'm like okay this is
you know um
that's one way to do it but you can also
just put it in your mouth scoop it down
wash it down it's not that bad like i
saw chin doing it one time i'm like oh
damn that's pretty savage you know but
and i wouldn't actually dry scoop
pre-workout i still don't quite believe
in that but
i'm on the dry scooping uh kratom tray
now so i use it for focus i use it as a
nootropic i really really really am
enjoying it and i hope that if you guys
haven't tried it yet you'll go to happy
hippo herbals.com
and use the code thick boy with three
c's for 20 off
up for the rest of your life okay use
kratom responsibly oh it's another week
and it's another oak and stone shirt
today what do i got on the short sleeve
flannel shirt in brown i love these
things yes the button's a little bit low
and i put it up here it doesn't matter
it's so you know i wear these to the
airport actually twice i wore this
flying this past weekend because it's
breathable my biggest fear on a plane is
that i get sweaty and hot so this has
been the perfect shirt for me to wear
around now i just wanted to pass on an
anecdote to you
because uh one of my training clients
paul
he ordered a shirt from oak and stone
for himself
he's about six foot two thirty and he's
like i ordered a large and came and it
was like a little bit too small i should
have gotten the extra large i'm like
yeah i could have told you that up front
why don't you listen to me
but he gave it to his son
now paul's in his late 50s his son is 15
years old his son loves the shirt can't
get enough of it and now paul is
ordering an xl for himself but he also
really liked the shirt so
i'm setting that up to say people of all
ages love oak and stone clothing i do
too super comfortable i always get
compliments on it and i hope you will
support oakenstone and the haters will
say podcast and helen mark harley by
going to oaklandstoneclothing.com
and using code
hella for 10 off you're hella gonna like
these clothes
to myself for because i just got back
from north carolina but before we talk
about that i want to talk about
what happened in arizona okay so you
know what i'm going to be talking about
here and that is the fact that i tried
to golf at topgolf and it didn't work
out so well and i had very low
expectations for how bad i was gonna be
and
golfing is harder than it looks
and you know it's hard and then you get
up there you're like
i don't know what to do with any part of
my body i don't know how far to stand
even though you've seen people golf your
whole life they make it look so easy
um
casey how long you been golfing
um so i played as a kid
so i i mean they had like a little
putter like cut off for me so i had like
a lot a little tiny putter um i played
on my high school team and then
i stopped playing
for
15 20 years and then my friends just got
into the golf like over cove you come
back yeah so uh i mean i changed my
swing but um i still had my the
fundamentals there yeah but you still
swing them things i swang them does
anybody in golf i actually say that uh
they do now yeah
as of right now
um
so you probably don't even remember what
it was like to learn no yeah sort of
like swimming i'm like i couldn't
imagine what it's like to like jump in a
pool it's like duh you do this yeah you
know with your arms yeah but as a kid i
never got a lesson or anything the only
thing that was like bragging i didn't
get a lesson i didn't get a lesson
born amazing uh the only thing that like
someone taught me probably my dad when i
was kid was like keep your left arm
straight so that was the only thing yeah
and so like i couldn't even figure out
which side i did it on because i'm
ambidex i don't know if ambidextrous is
the right word but i do certain things
with my right and then certain things to
my left so i was like i keep having i'm
like do i no they're both so awkward
yeah my brother shane is the same way he
swings righty but like he wants to putt
lefty
yeah like i write with my right hand and
yeah definitely throw with my left hand
but i was like oh you do yeah then you
may
so i was starting to pop you know
left-handed or swing left-handed but i'm
like
then i go right like i don't know the
whole thing was so confusing i wish
there was a video that i would show you
it was worse than i could ever imagine i
didn't want to look at it um i didn't
want anybody to take a video but
needless to say
uh it was a horrible embarrassment and
it's probably something i should work on
because i don't want to repeat that
embarrassment in the future if somebody
invites me
i don't want to have to be like look it
would be so damaging to my reputation
and your impression of me that i just
have to say no you want to you want to
show the folks at home yeah
you're like hey mark you got a sand
wedge on you by any chance and i said do
you have a sandwich that's a really
weird uh specific food request
look at this bad boy huh
so this is nice yeah it's all right this
is the hella golf portion of the uh yeah
man i've been waiting for you and you
know what now i can defend myself
against people with 24 fitness who come
and attack me all right there we go
bringing it all back so i wanted to get
that out of the way and then
i just went to north carolina had a few
cool things happen to me i you know
people do ask me like what are you to do
diet on the road no i don't
i just try to eat fewer meals and then
not worry about you know whether i'm
eating crap or not and try to get some
protein in you know have a breakfast and
have a dinner
get some movement in with walking and
then not worry about it too much and
then when i get back if i get fat you
know or gain weight or eat things that
make me retain water
i always and i've been doing this last
you know a few times i've done this fast
for 24 hours it's amazing what it does
and get a little bit of movement and
you'll probably be somewhat reset or
just at least feeling better because you
just don't want to fall into that
trap of like well i'm fat already so i
might as well get fatter and i've done
that many times in my life because it is
that vicious i kind of like when you do
drugs or you know like addiction
people have this notion i'm like i'm
just going to departing out of my system
and turns out that's not how it works
because
with addictive chemicals you just want
to do more of them you're never going to
get that cocaine out of your system if
you really like it if you really like
the smell
so
um but i learned something about stevie
blue
jay was telling me he's like oh yeah
stevie blue would just as soon as we
landed he'd get a bunch of eggs
and sweet potatoes and boil all the eggs
and cook the sweet potatoes and only eat
that the entire weekend and i'm like god
damn that is some impressive discipline
stevie blue
shout out stevie blue
you're the man
huge dick and diet discipline allegedly
um all right and at the shows i actually
wanted to shout out a couple people
a woman named katie
sweet woman brought her dad and
sometimes people like will
you know come up to me like oh my dad
wants to meet you and i'm like you can't
be serious you know like he's 72 and
it's his birthday i think he was 73
actually um
i mean it's like
again that's and i'm saying that because
it's it's cool i don't expect it i think
people are lying but it's happened a few
times like specifically elderly you know
like between 50 and 70 something right
they know who you are and it's just like
wow like it just reminds me like anybody
can listen to the podcast just because
you have this demo um or you know
specifically like they probably know me
through the fight or the kid but uh
anybody can listen and then you have
guys like this and he it was his
birthday he's currently dealing with
cancer treatment right now and
it
is really touching and memorable and
you know for me to see people at these
shows having those kind of experiences
because i do think live comedy is kind
of like
it's just such an invigorating
experience and so many people have never
done it you know like people come to l.a
and be like what should i do i'm like
have you ever been to live comedy
many people haven't there are some
people do it going to their first shows
that you know i noticed but
specifically she said
you know me and my dad had kind of been
estranged and then
we reconnected
over comedians
that's great you know um and sometimes
you do you can send each other like oh i
like you know
this comedian you send me that
and uh it becomes a sharing thing and
then you get into the podcast that these
comedians do
and so he was in fact aware of you know
the extended circle that includes thick
boy brendan brian chris and and i'm sure
many others but um
i just thought that was really
particularly heartwarming it reminded me
of when i before my dad died and one of
the things that like i never will feel
like
oh but i you know i couldn't imagine if
you were like
feeling estranged or you didn't say
something or do something but
the
after college i graduated and went home
to live with them
for a couple years and i was really down
on myself
because they didn't like i didn't know
what i was going to law school or
medical school or doing these things
that i saw my friends doing and felt
like well they're doing the impressive
stuff i should really do that even
though it was valuable time for me to
like
take acting and improv
classes and get better at what i would
ultimately do
and it allowed me to go to movies with
my parents
and i saw some amazing movies with my
dad like in real time and
i don't think i've told this before but
the last movie i saw with my dad was
called world's greatest dad with robin
williams and we had coincidentally seen
robin williams perform live twice
without knowing that he was gonna
perform so like at the throckmorton
theater in mill valley
they had this like tuesday night comedy
show with
good comedians but you wouldn't know any
of their names per se
and we twice randomly went there and
robin williams drops in and does an hour
and it's like the most memorable thing
ever because you're like oh my god i'm
in this like 100 person theater watching
robin williams like sweat you know his
tits off
like taking one audience suggestion and
then doing like an hour of stand-up
comedy it's insane and
so fortunate to have seen that
but
you know so he had kind of a special
meaning you know to me and then we see
this
this movie called world's greatest dad
which is like a super dark
movie have you seen it or know of it
okay
the plot is
robin williams is like this super nice
guy dad
um bobcat goldweight who makes
oh yeah world world's greatest dad with
bobcat yeah there we go um
bobcat gold plate makes some really
interesting films that again you could
like this couldn't be a studio movie
even the poster looks like and it's
robin williams the plot is
he comes in at his kid who he does like
everything for and the kid just treats
him like absolute garbage you know the
ultimate like entitled like bratty kind
of teenage high school age
you know just wants to play his video
games and tell his dad to [ __ ] off um
he walks in one morning to the kid's
room and sees that the kid had
uh
accidentally choked himself to death
while masturbating like with like a belt
around his neck which is also ironic
because that's you know how robin
williams uh committed suicide because of
the uh
you know louis body disease i forget
what the name is but
you know going crazy with the the
connections here today i know but
it always just makes me you know kind of
impressed at the universe that all these
little connections are there
he then rearranges the death to look
like something else and i forget what it
is exactly but it's like he basically
like
you know goes to work like making it
look accidental or what are like not
like he's just like you know got his
dick out and uh looking at porn
and
you know it's like this ultimate like
dad sacrifice you know thing
and my dad as many of you may know died
doing an open water swim to raise money
for a children's school in africa
how am i supposed to out dye him
that's what i'm asking
like how you know he set the bar so high
i'll never live up to the death of my
father no matter how hard i try
[ __ ] you rich
[Laughter]
god damn
and you know there was another guy who
came up to the uh this is going to be
segway into my next segment
but
it is another relevant conversation
shout out faisal
he came to a show
i want to say thursday he stuck around
and talked to us afterwards he gave uh
you know a gift bag it's always cool
people come out like they bought stuff
you already paid buy the ticket and now
you're buying stuff for other people so
you passed on some like gift card stuff
and
you know we get to talking and
you can tell he was like man i really
want to meet a girl and kind of awkward
or doesn't have like but you know by his
own admissions i don't i thought he was
like
you know there's nothing about him that
that i look at and go like no way you
could get chicks he's tall somewhat good
looking he goes to the gym has all these
elements
but
for some guys if you don't like
click into
certain
you know social practice right because
you don't have the right friend group
and you don't practice talking around
girls like you can kind of
go through your life not developing
certain
social skills or or even removing the
anxiety from talking to women which i
think is like one of the most important
parts right
um
when do you think you stopped being
anxious talking to women casey
do you have any conscious like
because it was like for me as a key like
you know i remember being attracted to
girls in seventh grade and being like
i'm definitely afraid of the hot ones
you know
not to be like i'm mr cool guys but i
really kind of wasn't i always just like
led with like jokes and stuff so like if
you're laughing if everybody's laughing
then they're just kind of knowing i
stumbled upon that like just out of
awkwardness i'm like oh if they're
laughing they seem to like
yeah want more of that you know but like
yes some guys do have
and i and i buy that you know like
a certain percentage of the population
so you're not a good guy to like teach
him how to get girls because you've
never had to struggle like right at
least with the social aspect of it like
it's like well just be yourself but it's
like no what if i'm awkward right
now i just
i think because there's so much like
when you talk to a guy like that
you know people will give you these sort
of trite pieces of advice like just be
more confident or you know you got to
just do this you got to um like flip
some switch you know to be cool and not
care or let it go or be not you know
it's like but okay you're that it you do
want to be more confident but there's 20
steps in the middle of that you know
luckily for anybody
who's watching this or who knows
somebody who could benefit from
you know more game
and speaking you read the game right
okay because i think that's a really and
i told them to read this just because
it's a it's a narrative about a guy neil
strauss who went from like
short dorky nerdy bald can't get women
to
ranked as the number one pickup artist
in the world whatever that means but it
was like you know in the pickup artist
community
his skills were world renowned and it
all had to do with like things that
really don't have to do with like he's
not an objectively good looking guy you
know
or like sexy in the conventional ways
but you can make up for that you can
learn these techniques and
a big big part of that is just
stopping being awkward around roman
because of your anxiety you know um
because most guys will get around a hot
woman and just start to act different
and freeze up and not be
fun and improvisational and
you know
loose right so that's part of it
there are so many resources on youtube
you know for how to text women how to
talk to women how to even and that's
sort of like an after thought of like if
you develop your masculinity if you
pursue excellence if you do all these
other things that have to do with
self-improvement you're also going to
get more women right like it doesn't
have to the game is a good example of
like if you're just looking to like put
on a fuzzy shirt and a big hat and like
use canned lines to like have sex with a
woman tonight that's there's a pretty
good blueprint in there
if you're actually looking for
a long-term relationship where you're
being your authentic self
you know you develop your masculinity if
you're
a straight guy looking for girls and
um you pursue excellence and you know
there are these
step-by-step blueprints because i can
look at the things he sent me some texts
that you know he's sending to like women
and it's like this block of time
that is a two-sentence text that you
need to send right you know sounds good
talk to you soon it's like yes i believe
that if we are aligned in this way that
i will totally respect you and i'm like
it's like whoa you do not need to say
all that and a lot of guys don't know
but it's like
you take things for granted that if you
had to explain to somebody else it's
like
what do you mean you shouldn't tell a
woman she's pretty like every day
that you're not dating
good morning beautiful
not always the best
approach
but again it all does come down to you
know you do want to be more confident
women love confidence but how you get
there is the tricky part
and you can't just
pretend you do ultimately have to do
things that make you more confident and
the gym is a big part of that
but also get some cool facial hair right
i mean come on you're talking to the
coolest facial hair
in this whole building obviously you
have more of it and it's better but you
know i'm pulling up the rear here
the number two spot that's fine if i
could grow a beard you know but i do
minoxidil my face it's just there's more
than there was it just i started with
four hairs on each side so
my problem is too much hair my back is a
goddamn disaster there you go see i'll
take that it's a trade-off it's a
trade-off no beard no back here though
so i bring that up also because he came
back and gave brendan a book by david
goggins if you haven't read david
goggins
can't hurt me
you should either in a hard copy or i
listen to the
audio book
do you say you read books if you listen
to the audio yeah yeah okay
because i was like i always feel like i
need to clarify somebody's gonna catch
me later wait a second you said you read
it
but it's on your audible account
the reason i recommend the audible
version is because he talks in between
the chapters and if you don't know david
goggins i realize not everybody does but
he's like former navy seal who's
insanely motivational and he does crazy
[ __ ] it's like i'm gonna go run a
hundred miles like when i haven't
trained for it you know he's had an
insane transformation going from a fat
power lifter basically down to
um you know he had to lose like a ton of
weight in a certain amount of time to
even be considered for the navy seals
got sick during two of them on the third
you know buds training he finally made
it and it's just a harrowing journey of
like everything being thrown at him and
his refusal to quit
um under any circumstances bringing
himself to the brink of death you know
and having
just an incredible rock solid unshakable
mentality
you know that i always liked the phrase
he used taking souls like when somebody
doubts him or somebody wants to put a
roadblock in front of him or say you
can't do this he's like i'm going to
take your soul
and meaning like i'm going to beat you
at the thing that you doubted me on i
just love that mentality because you
know it sounds kind of petty or
something because like you should only
be competing with yourself he's like
well i don't know like sometimes even
target be like [ __ ] you drill instructor
i'm taking your soul today
that can be very motivating and then
furthermore his upbringing is just to
the stand and probably accounts for the
reason that he does these crazy things
or you know there's a certain screw
loose like he had to deal with a lot of
violence
and his multiple families witnessing his
stepfather get murdered abusive father
to begin with moving around
um crazy stuff one of the stories like
you sitting in a school bus and this
like kid's head gets run over who's like
trying to bring cookies to the bus
driver he like trips and like falls
under the wheel as it lurches forward
and he's like he basically describes it
looking like a watermelon that just
exploded you know so it's like this
you're like that didn't happen right
that couldn't have happened the
interstitial chapters
you're talking to the guy who wrote it
with him and he's like i had to fact
check everything you said here so like
this is one of the ones i'm like this
can't be true and then you're like oh
yeah like detroit 19 you know 79 or
whatever so
i i know i'm just i'm using that as a
more extreme example of like he says
crazy things in the book that he did but
the book has been thoroughly fact
checked unlike for example american
sniper
yeah i beat the crap out of jesse
internavar
no you didn't you know i want to get
into some fun stuff now okay
we got these little clips here this is
my new favorite uh instagram fitness
influencer papito bro let's turn this up
he's got some great advice actually i
love this
he says
if you jacked people are not gonna [ __ ]
with you which is true
like that's a benefit dude fighting has
nothing to do with having muscles but
people will always say oh man i'm not
going to miss you it's like no i don't
like
it's the skinny guy with the cauliflower
ears that you need to worry about
not the guy who spends all day bench
pressing i'm sure i'd rather be strong
in a fight than not what is this one
do you want this small balls
poppy so he says if you're gonna take
the juice
your balls are gonna shrink which is
true fortunately you can reverse that
with hcg and clomid okay but it is a
fair warning don't think that your balls
are going to get bigger or even stay the
same size over time you have to make
sacrifices if you want to get jacked and
finally i love this meme i saw
dudes take one picture in a suit then
start posting quotes about success just
go to the wedding bro
how true is that like yeah and i love it
just i know someone and it just popped
into my head yeah that's uh
man yeah cause like that that would be
the only time i'd wear a suit you know
like and i'd have to go
buy it from men's warehouse or rather
pick one up that i bought like a year
ago and like you know got it tailored
and then didn't pay for that
do you still have my suit gotta go to a
wedding gotta pretend to be successful
for a few minutes
but i do love a cow tube like you ever
see this one where it's like a picture
of somebody in a suit looking at his
phone smiling
that's like the classic like
entrepreneur like i don't i try not to
follow those okay no sometimes they'll
follow me and they'll have a blue check
but then it's like
you have like a hundred thousand
followers like 160 likes and you're like
something's up you know but like you
know
about bitcoin
exactly it's always like bitcoin
something right like some weird like
entrepreneur i'm a crypto expert
suit and looking at your phone or like
like smiling at your laptop it's always
like here i am working just a candid
picture of me working
all right bro science academy i wanted
to go over quickly i did the chest last
time
the components and principles of a good
back workout right just to break down
how i think about it i'm not saying this
is the best workout this is you know the
most scientifically proven to get you a
jack back but it's how i approach it in
order to keep the same principles week
to week and also incorporate variety
you're either you know you're gonna
alternate between these two things
starting off with a heavy compound
movement that will either be a pull down
you know for something that's going to
affect your lats and teres more or a
heavy row bent over row
um
you know a machine row i really like
hammer strength rows you can really load
it up and anything that's chest
supported obviously you can just kind of
you know you take your back out of it i
do think it's good to use bent over
barbell rows to learn that position and
also as a
lift that will directly benefit your
deadlift because getting in a vulnerable
position like that and
uh you know
getting deep into a hip hinge while also
controlling a barbell with your upper
back muscles that's kind of key to
actually deadlift form i've found is
most people whose hips shoot up it's
like oh you haven't learned how to like
essentially engage the entire barbell
with your upper back to make all that
stiff right if your if your lats are
loose when you try to lift only your
hips go up right if you have it super
tight you know it's kind of like how do
you have to learn how to do a static
contraction with your back and
rowing helps that right but you're
starting out with either or
a heavy row or a heavy pull-down
lat pull-down machines are great
um but also
like the weighted dip the weighted
pull-up is one of these things like if
you can advance if you just did weighted
pull-ups for the rest of your life as
the one thing you did for back you would
have a pretty jacked back right and it
also requires the least amount of weight
and machinery because it's like if you
can
get a few plates
and a pull-up bar and a belt like you
have almost all the overload you need
and casey i was going to bring up
earlier
casey has a great home set up that i saw
recently
you have rings i have rings yeah what
else
so i have to bring through your doorway
yes i have these pull clamps like that's
not the regular like uh thing that hooks
on and goes straight across yeah
so
uh yeah they hook on and then i
carabiner rings from there yeah so you
had a slightly more advanced setup but
it's not the typical like it's hanging
from the doorway
that seems to make it less damaging to
your doorway specifically oh yeah yeah
they're like nice and grippy and like
they don't do any damage to the walls
either you're pushing it into the sides
like this and then like i've had the
paint come off because it sucks it so
hard that you like cup it's like oh it
dug in and like ripped it back out or
it's like
pushing into the frame of the door up
here something's you know gonna give but
i was like oh this doesn't look like
it's doing any damage
and you've got rings and handles so it's
like this
an upgrade just because
the ability to twist your
wrists for different angles with back
stuff is super important
and then what else do you have
just in general yeah i have a barbell
kettlebell i have uh little parallettes
yeah jump rope and i would consider
those it's like you know the minimalist
home gym if you have those things you're
kind of set you know you could do a
tremendous amount especially even just
with the rings it's like between abs
pull-ups dips
you know because that's always the thing
it's like
if you can combine the like pull-ups and
dips for body weight stuff that gets
you know you're pushing and pulling
muscles
you could almost reduce it to that right
and i love parallett bars because you do
handstand stuff with them yeah and even
push-ups like if you do really low like
deep push-ups that it's a tremendous
benefit for hard gainers for chest stuff
it's always like you want to get a deep
stretch because it forces every muscle
out of that equation in the beginning
and just works your pecs because every
other muscle is in such a compromised
position that your chest has to take
over regardless of your sternum
structure
um but i love them for if like if you
can get to the point where you're doing
like even five deficit handstand
push-ups like you're gonna have big
shoulders um there's no way around it so
i you know it gives you these kind of
very simple
strength standards to work towards
um or even muscle you can do muscle ups
right
i can't
not that i've tried that hard but it's
like you know if you can do a muscle up
you have a strong back like so it's just
something to work towards that you can
make you know it's a progression to work
towards that you know if you can end up
at that place
no fancy machinery required but back to
what i was saying
you're either starting out
with
three to five sets of
uh i'll say two to five sets if you go
heavy enough heavy pull downs or heavy
rows right pull up some pull downs or
machine rows or barber rollers or even
really smith machine barbell rows i like
because it allows a little bit more
leeway
in the direction that you pull and your
ability to hold that contraction at the
top specifically to target your upper
back your trapezius right because you
can kind of almost like when i go to the
smith machine i make it a higher angle
in order to engage really the mid part
of your traps
you know
not here not here but that you know that
contraction right there which kind of
gives it from the back that's really
what you're trying to build to kind of
like pop out from your back
and uh you know traps like your packs or
something that needs to be hit from all
angles to fully maximize it then we're
going into
you know to isolate after you've done
that like that is a back workout in and
of itself
you know um
a row motion a seated cable row also
counts i don't like to start with those
because i like to do something heavier
that's more full body but i love seated
rows as a secondary exercise if i do
like heavy weighted pull-ups then i'll
go to a
you know cable row if i start out with a
heavy barbell row then i'll probably go
to the lab pull down machine right
because i want to like start off with
the barbell or most basic overloading
exercise that i'm keeping track of and
i'm going
this time i hit this first and i
progressed in this way the other stuff
is hard as hell because depending on how
hard you push yourself it could be
compromising here so i don't go like my
third workout i didn't increase any
weight therefore i'm not getting
stronger
it doesn't matter
you're already fried
the other things are
either
a uh a cable stack pullover
you know you call both these pullovers
but it's a lat isolation movement what
do your lats do a lot of people don't
realize this
you know because like oh do i do wide
grip this doesn't get your lats more
this gets your terry's more
your lats make you come in here right so
if you can take everything else out of
that if you take your bicep out of it
now you're only pretty much using your
lat a little bit of your rear delt
but
i love doing um getting going up to the
cable stack getting either a bar is good
a tricep rub makes it a little harder
but you can you know pull it off again
to kind of like come in here and bring
it a little bit farther than you would
the bar either one works i like to go
higher reps because if you anything
under 10 reps to failure
you feel a ton of tension in your abs
almost too much you'll get tension in
your abs to stabilize yourself and it's
a good ab movement like secondarily but
like if you can't do like don't do five
rep sets of you know cable pull downs
that's stupid
also i alternate that if i'm if i did
that that day the next time i'm gonna
come in and do
uh dumbbell pullovers this is also good
for shoulder mobility in general i get
as deep as i can even with my messed up
shoulders i still you know can do that
even though it's somewhat painful but i
have better shoulder mobility than
people who have totally healthy
shoulders because i practice things like
that let it sink let it stretch your
lats and it also activates your pec
minor you might notice that
when you do these you'll feel a little
something here and that's actually
something i struggle with i think it's
like underdeveloped because of my
shoulder stuff so
i'll do that get a pump say i should do
this more and then don't do it but you
know it's good you can go heavy on it um
and it's just like one of these classic
bodybuilding movements and then i'll
typically finish off with either a rear
delt
isolation movement or a shrug isolation
movement like for traps you know
standing
hex bar if i want to go heavy
barbell is good and i'm you know i used
to go really really heavy trying to
build my traps
six seven plates just because the range
of motion so tiny you know and even just
standing statically
holding a bar it does work your traps
tremendously because that's really your
traps are designed to you know prevent
your
clavicles from falling off your skeleton
so you know they're under tremendous
stress just holding that and just
getting a stretch like a farmer's walk
right
but
again i'll just finish off with one of
those
i like dumbbell
you know dumbbells a little bit more
because you can
adjust your range of motion it's not
hitting your dick every time that's
really the main thing is barbell shrugs
hit your dick we don't want any of that
or
uh you know so if i'm not doing the trap
exercise i'm gonna do rear delt flies on
the machine those are great or
bent over rear delt flies
at a slight angle you don't need to go
like this it doesn't need to be
perfectly out right that puts stress on
my shoulder you're still doing the same
thing if you kind of create a almost
like a 45 degree angle backwards
you end up here right leading with your
elbows try to pause don't go so heavy
that you're just flapping up and down
you know something that you can actually
control and slow down a little bit if
you do those things if you rotate
through those
four basic ideas back and forth starting
with either a row or pull down
isolate the lats in some way and then
finish off with a with the rear delt iso
or a trap iso and rear delt iso also
does get your traps to some degree
you're gonna have a jack back by summer
i guarantee it or your money back psych
this is free in your face
now
dude we got somebody this way we can't
have nice gems i am so
uh-huh so in the spirit of last week
with the basketball stuff oh
and he does the scorpion at the bottom
of the pool
he looks shocked that's the funny thing
about this is he actually looks like he
didn't realize he was diving into a
three-foot pool
and uh it's just the most classic like
you know your parents probably told you
like oh watch out you can break your
neck
diving you know you always see a little
cartoon of the guy jumping in
and
this guy's the embodiment of
stupid diving principles
why was he so excited i have so many
questions like you know
what made you laugh this time just
seeing his body because no i mean like
you you would think that would kill you
right like
yeah people have died from us but i
think actually you know what's funny i
remember seeing this concussion video
that they showed you playing football
you have a lot more flexibility to bend
your neck that way than this way like
you know spinal injuries apparently
happen like if you're like putting your
head down and it has to go this way so
you know
you're lucky kid
what do we got here
this guy i was like
soaking fat like did he just slap him on
the back with a 45 pound plate and then
spot him
a little too close people always get
like right up front it's like dude he's
fine with the weight you get up and you
know
immediately hug him and put your crotch
to his ass
i'm not going to judge them i'm sure
they're very close and he just wants to
support but it's pretty extreme you've
never seen somebody get like you've seen
people slap before i've never seen
somebody hit another man with a plate on
the back yeah that's excessive yeah i'm
gonna do that to brenda next time when
he's not looking you're like no brenda
you got this whack
this is just something i related to do
all gym rats have this toxic trait
throwing your phone on the floor yeah
because we're like
wait until the very last moment look at
her phone oh [ __ ] i gotta do it and toss
it to the side right
let the chips fall where they may
this was you know i think a lot of gym
humor is stupid like these little like
pranks and stuff like that i'm so
annoyed by them this i was like okay
that's good
this guy goes up to somebody else in the
gym a stranger has his little he goes
can you spot me can you stand on my feet
so i can do crunches and he comes up and
he's just like ah
and the guy just has to stand there i
mean you know you're putting people in
this awkward position because what are
you gonna do like whoa
that looks gay and run away now you're a
homophobe congratulations
so you got to sit there
and deal with the fact that another man
is pantomiming giving you a bj in the
middle of a gym
but it also shows how secure you are
with your sexuality and i'm just going
to keep them coming i thought this was
funny because i always think about this
like people do smelling salts and i'm
like i wonder what the actual percentage
increase in a lift is going to be have
we measured that before this granny kid
does smelling sauce
he
and then his friend just trips over and
almost like you know breaks his face on
a on the floor
one more time buddy run like and why was
nobody spotting him in the first place
there's nobody behind there this kid
obviously can't do 315 not even close
and then he trips and takes his sweet
ass time getting up all right what do we
got next
uh-huh this is the danger i tell you to
bail like this guys i do but if you got
a ponytail oh might not be a great idea
this absolutely yanks back
[Music]
that could have been much worse like if
her feet were trapped the wrong way you
know
just break both patella tendons watch me
almost die with 900 pounds this isn't
even funny this is just like people
forget how much weight this is right
like this guy is
super jacked he's thick as hell
and he's shaking under the weight like
back and forth he ah comes up out of the
hole he almost gets it but then it's
like yeah you literally need you know
three other people to put it back in
place that's scary better that went
better than i thought right yeah i was
just like i thought it was interesting
because i'm like
it it the video gives you a sense of how
much weight 900 pounds is is that even
if you walk it out the wrong way like
the inertia that makes it vaseline is
bananas right and that probably throws
off your whole lift too heavy in my
opinion
i'm not lifting it um
okay you know here's another little reel
here for a lot of people been asking me
because i thought this was an um and a
lot of people do ask me this do people
treat me differently or you know
even just being muscular i've had the
experience if i was like up to 250 255
in college after taking a few cycles
then i kind of
rejected that i was like i just want to
look normal and i got down to like 2 14
and you know in the year after i playing
college football running a lot getting
lean just kind of looking you know
normal with some muscles all natural um
not mad at it people still you know
apparently thought i had a nice body so
that's one of these things where like
you know
steroids are not for girls you can look
to have a totally normal physique and
just look good with shirt off and women
are totally fine with that um
and
since then since putting on more muscle
in my 30s i do see and by the way the
the pic you know the thing here if
you're listening to the podcast
can we back up a little bit and just see
what the uh
yeah men who have a very fit physique do
you really get more attention compared
to when you weren't as fit so that is a
legitimately interesting question on
this page that i guess asked me you know
read it you just post questions 100
don't let anyone tell you otherwise
that's coming from a former
scrawny guy who put on just enough to
fill out worlds of difference even in
how uh women treat you with respect
and remember guys
women don't [ __ ] guys that they don't
respect they can hate you and respect
you and so [ __ ] you
thanks andrew tate for that little
nugget of uh truth but yes it is
interesting how people treat you
differently you get more attention i
don't feel like i thrive off attention
but
i do at the same time no
i do i do embrace that i am an extrovert
and i do think that one of the things i
like is
i like talking to strangers and like
kind of having these random counters but
like
there's
in normal situations there's often a
barrier because like what's going to
break the ice what's going to be the
common ground it turns out that wearing
a suit of muscles is common ground for a
lot of people because either you you're
also buff and they can talk about
lifting or
they look at you and they like it's a
very neutral like you can't walk up to a
girl and be like i like your tits you
know but you can kind of go up to a uh
you know a person and say like muscles
teach me how to work out and i'm like
down bro
um
you know and so
you know
it's something that i don't think i
would go away from that because i like
the opportunities it opens up
just as far as meeting literally just
meeting people it's a conversation
starter and you can get into knowing
somebody just by having muscles so
that's my advice of the day is
you want more people to talk to you on
the street take steroids get jacked grow
your hair out
have premature gray hair simple as that
that's the mark harley formula for
strangers being confused by you now
that being said let's get on we got to
do the liver kingdom of the week because
this one this is two videos and it's
gonna set up
um
this uh final meme here let's see what
he says
[Music]
i know i don't know my rosin goal is i'm
to do peds prioritize execute and
dominate right so he's i love how he's
leaning into this
i love always leading into this uh you
know the pd's trolling us so brilliantly
this is another one that's the same
thing i just wanted to set it up and
they do the little voice like the not
fit memes guys are amazing um if it's
not loaded we can just go back to the uh
the uh picture there because
yeah i do peds prioritize execute
dominate entren
so you know ultimately
you control us liver king but we're
going to show you back and we're always
going to be better
so
um
look i just want to say my message for
the week to everybody
i want you to get out there
and
prioritize execute dominate and bully
the [ __ ] out of life
you